hey guys Alexa right here standing in
for Peter Brown let's talk about Tony
Hawk's Pro Skater 5 Tony Hawk's Pro
Skater 5 momentarily recalls the
greatness of earlier games in the series
skating around and looking for
opportunities to test your creativity
and reflexes is sometimes as enjoyable
today as it was 10 15 years ago
however these moments of excitement are
fleeting the core mechanics are there
but the supporting systems are
half-baked and rickety for anyone who's
played Tony Hawk games in the past
skating pulling off tricks and forming
combos in Tony Hawk pro skater 5 will
come naturally and it's accessible for
newcomers too however the same button
that's used to grind is also tied to the
new slam action which forces your skater
and their board downward you can use it
to your advantage if you've missed time
the distance between takeoff and landing
during a combo but you can no longer
buffer a grind in midair because you
instantly plummet to the ground
of course skating sessions are only as
good as the locations they take place in
and the eight maps in Tony Hawk pro
skater 5 are too small lacking and
interesting opportunities they're also
ugly with poorly drawn textures and
constant texture pop-in pulling off
combos often requires identifying a
series of loosely connected objects that
you can grind on between air based
tricks and there are a few cleverly
hidden wants to be found but nowhere
near as many as in past games some maps
will frustrate you in other ways beyond
their lack of interesting elements it's
all too easy to hit a ramp or jump off
other objects only to find that you've
gone out of bounds Tony Hawk's Pro
Skater 5 also features a shakey cam that
activates when you ride over rough
terrain or whenever the game feels like
it frame rates are also an issue and
it's not uncommon that you fall through
geometry clip through it and ruin a
combo or fall victim to anomalous
physics course progressing from map to
map requires that you collect stars by
performing various feats and completing
challenges these can include reaching a
high score collecting items or pushing
balls out of a pool among a few others
these tasks very little from map to map
and they are indeed tasks because they
never deliver an enjoyable or
challenging experience
your only motivation to play them are
these stars to unlock maps and skill
points that can be used to increase your
abilities though they never make a
tangible difference your skater feels
the same on day one as he does on day 5
Tony Hawk's Pro Skater 5 is built as an
online game but it does little to entice
you into playing with others according
to Peter he was never paired with more
than one other person outside a free
skate
were times when a multiplayer challenge
would start with him as the sole
participant online connectivity gets in
the way during single-player missions -
if you're connected to the Internet when
you're trying to play single-player Tony
Hawk pro skater 5 still tries to connect
to a server if it has any problems
during this process you have to wait for
it to timeout disconnect your console
from the internet and try again
beyond the boring levels and challenges
Tony Hawk pro skater 5 has another big
problem with organization and
presentation when scrolling through the
main menu you're presented with a few
options levels my levels and player
created levels the game teases you with
more to do by placing arrows on the top
and bottom of the list as though you can
scroll to see more but it does the same
thing on the map selection screen
creating the illusion that there's more
to the game than there actually is once
you're playing a challenge there's no
way to exit it besides returning to the
game's main menu and even if you stick
with it and wait for the time when it
took away you'll have to endure a series
of loading screens before you can head
back to skating Peter tried his hardest
to engage with the activities in Tony
Hawk's Pro Skater 5 to eke out enjoyment
but problems with menus loading screens
and glitches made it all too easy to put
down the controller and walk away within
Tony Hawk's Pro Skater 5 lies a basic
skating game that's difficult to enjoy
because you have to jump over numerous
hoops and ignore a plethora of obvious
issues to find the smallest amount of
fun previous Tony Hawk games were able
to capture your imagination and motivate
you through character progression here
interesting levels and even a great
soundtrack the soundtrack in this game
is good enough but it's riddled with
technical glitches and design missteps
making it a huge step back for the
series